Okay. So, good morning. Today we are
doing the crusades which um will lead us
into the Renaissance, the Protestant
Reformation and the Slamic Revolution.
Okay. Um three questions we are looking
at today are what are the
crusades? Second question is why did
they happen? The third question is why
did they stop? Okay, those are the three
major questions we are looking at today.
In order for me to um explain the
answers, I first need to provide a lot
of background.
Okay, first of all um is in the
beginning of Christianity in the Bible
um the early Christianity was a religion
of two things humility and poverty.
Okay. So let me tell you a story from
the Bible to illustrate this. One day
Jesus and his disciples were out
preaching and then a young man comes to
Jesus and
says, "I loved your sermon. I want to
know how to be a better person." And
then Jesus says to
him, make sure you follow the ten
commandments and the laws of the
prophets. And the young man says,"I have
a very pious man. I already do this. I
want to do more." And then Jesus says to
him, "Then do this. Give up all your
wealth. Give it give your wealth to the
poor and then follow me and then you
will have all the treasure in the
kingdom of heaven." The young
man was uh really distraught because he
was very very wealthy and he didn't want
to give up his wealth. So he walked
away. Then Jesus turned to his disciples
and he
said it is easier for camel to go
through the eye of a needle which is say
it's impossible okay than for a rich man
to enter the kingdom of God. Okay. So
here Jesus is negating wealth. And this
is a revolutionary idea at that time
because for people in the western world,
the entire point of believing in God,
the entire point of making sacrifices to
your gods is to have more wealth in
life, right? How do you know if God
favors you? Well, you become wealthy.
All right? So what Jesus is saying here
is revolutionary meaning you should live
a pious life so that you may enjoy
um a good life in heaven. Okay. So
that's the heart and soul of the
Christian religion and what makes it
different from previous religions. That
said, the Catholic Church is
probably the wealthiest and most
powerful religious organization ever in
human history. We have absolutely no
idea how wealthy the Catholic Church is.
Okay, their their wealth is
immeasurable. Uh this is St. Peter's
Basilica, the church in the Vatican
where the Catholic Church is based.
inside this church is a lot of gold.
Okay, a lot of gold. So, in its um
thousand years um um um close to 2,000
years of history, the Catholic Church
has amassed more money than God. All
right. So, how do you explain this
contradiction? How is it that the
Catholic Church was able to amass so
much
wealth? Okay. So um as we discussed
after the fall of Rome the Catholic
Church basically became the new Roman
Empire. Um after the fall of church
after the fall of Rome for the longest
time Europe was poor but starting about
the year 1000 Europe became increasingly
wealthy for a variety of reasons.
The main reason is um something called
the medieval warm period. Meaning it was
just easier to grow crops. Okay. That
followed the invention of the watermill,
windmill and horse collar which made it
easier for people
um to grow crops. This this is what I
call the mini agricultural revolution.
Because of this excess wealth, you saw
the rise of cities, urban centers and um
this allowed Europe to start trading
with the rest of the world
primarily the um abbiset caliphat which
we discussed last week um and as such
Europe became increasingly wealthy okay
but what's important for us to remember
is with wealth comes
inequality so this is this also marks
the high point of feudalism ism. You
have too many
people, too little land, and as a
result, uh, you have feudalism, okay?
Where the nobility controls all the
land. The peasants became poor,
dependent, and often
indebted. So, as you can see, these are
the major city centers of Europe as at
this time. Um, this the wealthiest city
in Europe is still uh Consenipole,
right? But you have uh Rome, London,
Paris all emerging as major
um
manufacturing and urban centers. What's
important for us to remember also is
that around this
time one of the wealthiest parts of
Europe is Spain. Okay, this is important
because Spain is not Christian. It's
Muslim in the year 1000. All right, and
this and this will create conflict
between Europe and Spain. All right. So
how was the church able to amass so much
power during this time? Well, because
the church
pioneered a new way of controlling
people that was not possible before.
Okay. So to illustrate this point, let's
compare an empire with a church, the
Catholic Church. First question, who's
in charge? Well, in an empire, the
emperor is in charge, but he's a human
being who is flawed and mortal. He will
eventually die. He's also subjective.
People understand that he will make
mistakes. So, that's why you must appeal
to him. You must try to convince him.
But with the Catholic Church, the person
in charge is God who is
perfect, immutable, and eternal. He can
never make a mistake and he will always
be there. Okay. Second difference is an
empire demands labor from you. It
demands that you toil and
sweat. But the church demands your soul,
your
eternal spiritual
obedience, your heart and your mind.
Okay. And the third major difference is
an empire can only put you to death as
the worst punishment. But the church can
sentence you to eternal damnation. The
church can have you burn in hell for
eternity. Okay? And that's and so this
concept of eternal damnation is the
source of a lot of the church's uh
power.
Okay? So the church had something called
a faith monopoly. It was the only
religion. It was a true religion. Um,
and so there are certain ways that this
power would express and benefit itself
in Europe at this time. Okay, I I'm I'm
I'm going to have to go through um a
lot. This is a lot of information. I
apologize, but you will need to know
this in order for us to go on in the in
the course. Okay, this is especially
important for the Protestant Reformation
because the Protestant Reformation will
be a rejection of a lot of these
practices. Okay. All right. So the first
thing you need to understand of the
church in about the year 1000 is it's an
imperial bureaucracy. The pope is
basically the emperor and then each
region has um bishops that control the
region. It's a huge bureaucracy that's
not that's very similar to the
bureaucracy in uh consent as well as in
China. Okay, it's a top-down hierarchy.
Second thing you need to know is the
official language of the church was
Latin. During church services, the
priest would give sermons in Latin. The
Bible was written in Latin. The purpose
for this is to tell people that the
Bible that theology was not for them.
They just had to listen and obey. Okay?
So that gave the priest a lot of power.
Um, it was also an explicit rule that
only priests could preach the Bible. You
you had to be ordained and authorized by
the church in order to be able to tell
what Christianity meant.
Okay. Um, you had to recite nine creed
which is a holy trinity. Okay. So
remember we discussed the holy trinity,
the idea of monotheism and this is the
dominant belief system of the church.
There's something called the sacraments,
okay? Um, seven holy sacraments that you
must pay for. And these are rituals
provided to you by priests in the
church. What these rituals are trying to
do is they're trying to channel divine
energy of heaven and Jesus and God in
order to make your life much more
fortunate. Okay. So, an example of this
is called the eukarist. And and so in
the Eucharist employs the principle of
transmutation. So during the Eucharist
and it's a basically common meal, what
the priest will do is he will channel
Jesus from heaven and his body will
become expressed in bread. Okay? The
bread will become the body of Jesus. And
then his blood will manifest in wine or
water. Okay? And then you will feast on
the bread and wine. You eat Jesus. You
drink Jesus. And Jesus comes into you.
All right? And if this sounds weird, it
it is weird. And that's why the
Protestants, a lot of Protestants will
rebel against this. They think it's
superstitious. All right? You also have
the church determining who goes to hell,
heaven, and purgatory as well as for how
long. Hell is where you burn for all of
eternity. Heaven is where you are with
God. Purgatory is if you commit sins and
you need to you need to cleanse yourself
of these sins. So you you might be in
purgatory for like one year if you
steal, but you might also be there for a
thousand years if you killed someone.
Okay? And the church, it's up to the
church to to determine how long you're
in purgatory for. Um there's something
called the canonization of saints where
the church can determine who are saints.
A lot of Protestants in the future will
say this is wrong because only the Bible
only Jesus can determine who is worthy.
Okay, the church doesn't have the power
to to determine this. The last thing is
and this is really important. The
authority of the clerics was
absolute and heretics were those who
denied the absolute authority of the
church. Okay. So um this is important
because some people think that heretics
are those who disagree with the church.
For example
um they don't really understand the
missing creed. Well if you don't
understand something it's called
ignorance or superstition. You
understand? And therefore the church has
a responsibility to educate you. Once
the church educates you and you still
refuse to emit the authority of the
church then you become a heretic which
means you will become excommunicated.
Okay? Excommunicate means that you will
be kicked out of the community of the
church which means you will burn in hell
forever. as well. Um, you could also be
burnt at the
stake for uh being a heretic. Okay, does
that make sense? So, so these are the
sources of the power of the church. I
can as you can see at this time the
Catholic Church is a very elitist, very
aloof and very distant religion. Okay.
It's designed in a way as we move to be
removed
from the ordinary struggles of ordinary
people. Okay. So as you can imagine with
so much power comes corruption.
Augustine in the city of God he
basically imagine the intellectual
blueprint for the Catholic Church. He
believed the Catholic Church was this
had to be this eternal spiritual force
that represented God on earth. So what's
really important was for the church to
focus on spirituality but with power the
church slowly became more corrupted.
Okay. So let's look at some incidents of
corruption that were legal practices at
this time. Okay. The first is the idea
of indulgence. And this means that maybe
you committed a lot of sins, but you
have a lot of money. What you can do is
bribe the church to make your stay in
purgatory shorter. Okay, this is
basically bribery. All right, spiritual
bribery. And and obviously a lot of
Christians would have issues with this.
Okay, second is the idea of simony.
simply just means that if you're rich,
you can buy yourself into the church
regardless of your uh education,
regardless of your understanding of of
of the theology. Okay, this is called
simony. Then you have something called
the selling of holy relics. So again, at
this time everyone's very sus
superstitious. So they want to buy
relics in order to channel the divine
power of Jesus, right? Well, the church
would sell these relics and a lot of
them would be fake. But a lot of
Christians, as you can imagine, would
find the very idea of the church
engaging in commerce to be very
offensive. Worldliness means that you
have um the conjoining the conflation of
the nobility with the church. So a lot
of princes became bishops. Canes could
pick who could become uh bishops and
priests were supposed to be celibate.
They were supposed to devote their their
life to God. But a lot of them got
married, had kids and own property and
became very wealthy. Okay. So a
conflation of the nobility and the
church, a conflation of temporal power
with spiritual
power. Tiffs means that prisoners had to
pay taxes.
Prisonioners had to pay taxes to not
only the nobility but also to the church
as well. The very last idea is idea of
feudalism. And this means that the
church controlled at its height
onethird of all the land in Christian
Europe and they didn't have to pay taxes
to the nobility to the prince. So as a
result of all these of all this
corruption and special privilege, the
church became the most powerful
organization in all of Europe. Okay? And
again they had this power because people
were afraid of burning in hell for
eternity. Okay? Even kings were
afraid. But we have to remember this and
this is very important. Ultimately, if
you're a church, your power, your
legitimacy, your authority comes from
your ability to
enforce your belief system on everyone.
Okay? This what I call
orthodoxy. The church must enforce right
thinking, correct thinking on people. If
people disagree, if an increasing number
of people disagree, then your authority,
your power will decrease. Now at this
time in the year uh 1000 there are five
sources
of conflict for the church. Okay. Five
things that will question the legitimacy
of the church. The first thing is
this. The Muslims occupy the holy land.
Jerusalem right now is being controlled
by um the fatimates. Okay, which is an
Islamic caliphate. And that this is
embarrassing, right? Because if you are
the true representative of God on earth,
why is Jerusalem being controlled by the
Muslims? Okay, that's embarrassing.
Second problem is Muslim Spain. Okay,
it's more wealthy, more cosmopolitan and
innovative
than Christian Europe. A lot of the
reason why is Muslim Spain, it is much
more open, inclusive and tolerant than
the Catholic Church. It also trades with
the rest of the Muslim world. And as we
know from the Islamic Golden Age
lecture, the Muslim world right now is
very very wealthy. Jews, Christians, and
Muslims all get along very fine in
Muslim Spain. Okay? So, and it's just
right next door. Everyone can see that
Muslim Spain, it's much more wealthy. So
that's another
problem. A third problem is something
called the great shism of 1054. That's
when the Greek Orthodox Bisantine Church
in Conanopole, it it broke away. It
split split away from the Roman Catholic
Church in Rome. Now you have two
different churches all claiming to be
the one true church of Jesus. Okay,
that's a huge problem. Another problem
of course is the corruption that we that
we just discussed the conflation of
spiritual power with temporal ambition.
Okay. Now the last problem is this. The
last problem is the set. Now something
that we discussed a lot last semester is
that humans are first and foremost
religious.
Humans have religious needs and these
religious needs often trump their
material needs. For example, food,
water, and shelter. Okay? Humans have a
fundamental need for community,
intimacy, and truth. But the Catholic
Church is
denying intimacy and truth to humans.
Humans want to be with God. They want to
serve God.
But the Catholic Church says, "No, we
are the middleman. You have to go
through us in order to celebrate God."
Okay? So there's a lot of discontent at
this point in Christian Europe against
the Catholic Church. All right?
So these are five problems. And again,
the Catholic Church, the entire source
of their power is during their ability
to maintain orthodoxy.
So they developed a threeprong strategy
that they will use
basically a lot okay throughout uh the
history of Europe. Okay these
three-prong strategy are scapegoating,
persecuting and crusading okay and you
guys need to know this because these
three ideas will recur over and over in
European history. The idea of
scapegoating is this. In Europe at this
time, even though the Jewish community
is a lot smaller, it's still present.
Okay. Now, the question then is what are
the Jews still doing in Europe? And and
the answer is, well, a lot of them are
working for the nobility. Okay? The
nobility inherit their wealth, but they
don't want to do any work. They don't
want to manage their land. They don't
want to run their business. They don't
want to collect taxes and they don't
want to run their banks. So, they get
Jews to do this for them because Jews
are um clever, they're hardworking, but
most
importantly, they're completely
dependent on the protection of nobility.
Does that make sense? Because at this
point in Christian history, remember the
Catholic Church teaches Christians that
the Jews were responsible for
persecuting Jesus and therefore
Christians really don't like Jews. So if
Jews want to stay in Europe, if they
want to
um stay together as community, they are
completely dependent on the protection
of nobility and as such they essentially
become slaves to the nobility. They have
no choice but to serve the nobility.
This is bad for them because the
peasants don't like being exploited by
the nobility. Remember this is a feudal
system where peasants are too poor uh
and too indebted to the nobility. Okay.
But in their day-to-day interactions who
do they work with? They work with Jews,
right? Jews are the one who comes and
collects taxes for the nobility. Jews
are the ones who sell them
goods, right? So what happens over time
is the peasants the resentment against
nobility is channeled towards the
Jews. All right? So whenever there's a
major conflict guess who gets killed,
guess who gets persecuted? It's a Jews.
All right? And this is a pattern that
will be consistent
for basically all of European history.
Okay? Up until the Holocaust. If you
want to understand why the holoca
holocaust happened, this is why it
happened. Okay? There's a
long-term emity hatred of the European
people against the Jews created by the
nobility. All right? Um when the
conflict becomes too intense, what will
happen is the nobility will protect
themselves by expelling the Jews. Okay.
So in 1492, Spain expelled the Jews. But
before that, the Germans expelled the
Jews 1100, France in 1306. Okay. Um, but
before then, you have these massacres
going on all around uh Europe. All
right. So, the I'm not sure if you're
able to see the
black skull, but that's this massacre of
Jews. Okay. Right. So, being a Jew means
to be constantly persecuted. And again
they're being scapegoed by the Catholic
Church in order to reduce tensions
between the nobility and the peasantry.
All right. So that's the first uh
mechanism. Then you have uh the
crusades. All right. So to understand
the crusades, let me give some some
historical background. In the year 638,
in the year
638, the Muslims take over Jerusalem
from the Bison Empire. Okay? They
conquer it. And once they take it over,
they make Jerusalem into an open,
inclusive and tolerant religious
community where Christians, Jews, and
Muslims can celebrate their religion
openly. Okay. So after that, what
Christians have to do is make these
pilgrimages to uh Jerusalem. And for
most of this history, it's fine. There
are no issues. But what will happen is
as the Bison empire becomes weaker and
the Abassad caliphate becomes weaker
there's now chaos and as such uh bandits
roam the land and pilgrims find it more
and more um dangerous to venture into
Jerusalem. Okay, does that make sense?
All right. So now it's become much more
dangerous for Christians to venture into
Jerusalem because of all the internal
chaos going on in the Muslim land. The
people who are creating all this chaos
are called the Seljic Turks. Last class
we talked about the rise of Genghask
Khan, right? And what what I said last
class is the step people are always
invading agricultural empires. So this
the the the Turks um they are based in
central Asia and then slowly over time
they will conquer the Abbased Caliphat
and in 1071 they will begin to occupy
Jerusalem. Okay. And then and the Turks
leave Jerusalem alone but because of
this conflict what's happening is the
way to Jerusalem it's much more
dangerous as well. The Turks are now
threatening Baantium. Okay, Conenol
right here. In fact, they're conquering
a lot of territory in around Conanole.
And as such, the emperor of Conseniple,
the Bian emperor, he
appeals to Pope Urban II, who is the
head of the Roman Catholic Church. Can
you please help me and save me from the
Seljic Turks? And so what Pope Urban II
will do, remember popes are politicians.
He sees the opportunity here to unite
Christianom under the authority of Rome,
right? He sees the opportunity to
reclaim Jerusalem as Christian
territory. He sees an opportunity to
channel the religious energies of the
peasantry against the Muslims. Okay. So
what he does is in the year 10
um 95 he will give a
speech calling for the first crusade
which begins the crusading period. Now
we're going to look at very closely at
this speech and it's important we do
because this rhetoric this philosophy
will underpin
uh the relationship between Christians,
Muslims and Jews for most of European
history. Okay. So let's see how the pope
thinks. All who die by the way, whether
by land or by sea, or in battle against
the pagans, shall have immediate
remission of sins. Okay? The pagans are
non-Christians, the Muslims, the Jews.
Okay? So this so what the Pope is
calling for is a
jihad. All good Christians now must go
into battle to reclaim Jerusalem. And if
you do so, you will be granted immediate
access to heaven regardless of what you
did and how you sinned. Doesn't make
sense, guys. This is a jihad. He's
calling for
jihad. All right. The concept people
think comes from the Islamic world. It's
it's very much a Christian concept of
jihad where if you go to Jerusalem and
you die, you're going straight to
heaven. Okay? You'll be you you'll be
right beside God. Now he also says, "Oh,
what a disgrace if such a despised and
base race which worships demons." A
despised and base race which worships
demons. Okay, he's talking about the
Muslims. Muslims don't worship demons.
Muslims worship the same God as the Jews
and the Christians. In fact, a lot of
their religious practice is similar to
the Christians and Jews. when Muhammad
um and the Muslims came to conquer the
Holy Land, they did so in a peaceful
manner. Okay? They try to reduce as much
bloodshed as possible. And here, Pope
Urban II, he's spreading racism against
the Muslims. In fact, what the rumors
are is that in Jerusalem, Christian
women are being enslaved. Christians are
being massacred and kicked out of
Jerusalem. Christians are no longer
allowed into Jerusalem. These are all
rumors. They're all fake. They're not
true. But Pope Or the second, he is
trying to whip up this racist anger at
the Muslims,
okay? Should conquer a people which has
the faith of omnant God and is made
glorious with the name of Christ. It is
embarrassing for us as Christians that
the Muslims control Jerusalem. We must
fix this. Okay. All right. Let's
continue. Let those who have been
accustomed unjustly to wage private
warfare against the faithful now go
against the infidels and end with
victory this war which should have been
begun long ago. Why did we wait so long
to reclaim Jerusalem? They've had us in
6 638. It's now year it's now the year
10. It's now the year
1095. Why are we fighting ourselves? Why
why is there war in Europe? we should
all be going to to the holy land and
kill all the Muslims. Okay, again this
is important that that we read because
this rhetoric, this logic uh this
emotion is going to
um basically
basically justify the age of conquest,
exploration and imperialism which will
follow after this.
Okay. Let those who for a long time have
been robbers now become knights. Do you
understand? You could be the lowest
person on earth. You could be a thief.
But if you go on a crusade, you are now
a nobleman. You are now a knight. You
are now a hero, a valiant hero for for
Christianity. Let those who have been
fighting against their brothers and
relatives now fight in the proper way
against the
barbarians.
Okay? Let those who have been serving as
mercenaries for small pay now obtain the
eternal reward. This this is what he's
saying. If you go on this crusade,
regardless of who you are, you will be
honored by God. You will receive eternal
reward. Regardless of what you did,
okay? You could be the worst criminal in
Europe. It doesn't matter. Once you go
on this crusade, you will be saved.
Right? So, he makes this bargain with
the people of Europe. And as you can
imagine, there's a ground swell of
excitement.
Okay, a lot of people go on this crusade
against the the Turks. All right, so
let's summarize and look at the
individual reasons why people are going
on this crusade. It's a long way and
it's very dangerous, but they're very
excited to go. Okay, why? All right, so
the first reason is penance. So a lot
are violent people who have engaged in
war, right? They go on this crusade,
they will be forgiven for their sins.
It's either e either you go go on a
crusade or you go join a monastery.
Okay. Uh clical immunity. What this
means is that um if you are a criminal,
if you kill someone, if you go on a
crusade, you will be immune. You will be
absolved of these crimes. So, as you can
imagine, a lot of psychopaths go on this
crusade. A lot of criminals. Vengeance.
People are hearing rumors that um the
Muslims are killing Christian women. So
they want to kill Muslim men. Okay.
Elite overprouction. So as we discussed
when a society becomes much more wealthy
you have a problem of elite overp
production. Basically younger sons who
cannot inherit any land and so they must
go on a crusade to win over their own
land. Okay. To obtain their own land and
become nobility locally. Second coming.
Okay. And what this means is that okay
so in Christianity there are many
powerful ideas um the cru crucification
of Jesus is a powerful idea but the
second coming is the most powerful idea
it's the idea that eventually Jesus will
return and he will make the world a new
okay this is what drives a lot of
Christians and so a lot of Christians
believe that this crusade it's really
the end of the world it's a final battle
between the believers and the
non-believers and Jesus will return to
Jerusalem in order to fight on behalf of
the believers and usher usher in a new
world order. Okay, people actually
believe this um adventurism, romantism.
Okay, chivalry. Chivalry means chivalry.
Okay, we didn't discuss this but it's
important that it's important that you
know chivalry is a code of honor among
knights. Um the chivalry the principle
um a lot of the principle is loyalty to
your lord. So if your lord goes off on a
crusade, you have to join him. Okay? You
have to be loyal to to your master, to
your lord. Uh piety, fanatism, okay? And
glory. Okay? Why am I listing this?
Because guys, um these reasons are also
what drives the Europeans into the new
world. Okay? uh later on we we will be
discussing the age of exploration where
the Spaniards, the Portuguese, the
French, the British they go into the new
world and they're going into the new
world for these reasons and a lot are
going for with religious fever and
religious energy. Okay. So it's
important that that that you understand
the um complexity and diversity of
reasoning. Okay. So um as I mentioned
the year 1095 Pope Urban II declares the
first crusade but over the course of
next 200 years there'll be a series of
crusades to uh maintain the holy land.
Okay. Um and
um it's a very complicated process
because it's not being organized. Okay.
It's a very much a grassroots movement.
basically local lords are the ones
organizing
um these crusades and and often um
peasants will go by themselves. Okay.
And as you can imagine, as you can see,
it's a very long way to Jerusalem and a
lot will get killed along along the way,
right?
Um in the first crusade, the first
crusade is extremely successful because
at this point in in history, the Muslims
don't really care about Jerusalem. it's
not that important to them. So the
crusaders are able to take Jerusalem and
they establish something called the
crusader states and
um it's very very impressive that they
do so because they're completely
surrounded by Muslims and by enemies.
Okay. But because of their religious
fanatism, they will maintain these
crusader states for the next um 200
years. Okay. So, uh the the yellow are
crusader states and as you can see the
white is all Muslim
territory. All right.
Um, in 1099 they take Jerusalem. And as
I mentioned, there's a lot of religious
finm going on. When the crus crusaders
take Jerusalem, they do so with
vengeance. They kill all the Muslims.
They kill all the Jews. They basically
kill as many people as possible in the
city. before the siege um the Fatimids
who were in control of the city, they
actually expelled the Christians because
they were afraid that the Christians
would help the um crusaders from inside.
Okay, so no Christians were killed but a
lot of Jews, a lot of Muslims were
killed. It was a very very bloody event
and the Christians celebrate this. Okay.
They
um for them this is righteous to kill
the enemy for the glory of God. It is
righteous killing.
Okay. This contrast with the year 1187
when the Muslim leader named Saladin.
Okay, Saladin is considered one of the
greatest warriors in human history. He's
celebrated both by Christians and
Muslims. He takes Jerusalem without
killing any Jews. Christians or Muslims.
Okay? He does so peacefully. And again,
what's important for us to remember is
that
historically, Christianity has been a
very
violent religion. And Muslims, there's a
lot of violence, but it tends to be much
more peaceful, open, and inclusive than
Christianity. Okay? I'm not talking
about today, but I'm talking about
historically this has been true.
Um once they control Jerusalem, there
are five major military orders
um of the crusaders. Okay, you've
probably heard of the Knights Templar.
Okay, they're the most famous. But you
also have a group called the Tatonic
Knights who will go on to found a place
called Prussia which will unite Germany.
Okay. So, so I I I want you guys to
remember the Tatonic Knights uh because
they will form the basis of Persian
society which will then um unite Germany
into modern day Germany. Um they come
from different places in Europe and and
that's why there are five different
military orders.
Okay. Um the Knights Templars are the
most famous and they become over time
extremely influential and powerful. The
reason why is they're really the first
multinational organization in Europe. So
they were meant to protect pilgrims
along the way to Jerusalem. But what
they really did was um pilgrims would
give their money to the Templars for
safekeeping and then when they got to
Jerusalem the Templars would give the
money back. Okay? So they were a bank
and as you can imagine as a bank they
were able to make a lot of investments
they were able to trade and as such
because they're bankers and they're
traders they are much more sophisticated
well educated and
cosmopolitan than the Catholic church
right the Catholic church isn't an
imperial bureaucracy it's only cares
about maintaining orthodoxy over Europe
but the knights templars uh they are
bankers they're traders
also once Once they take over Jerusalem
and now they have to govern a city, they
recognize that you need to work with
Jews and Muslims. Okay? Because Jews and
Muslims have these business connections
all around the Muslim world and they're
surrounded by Muslims. So what will
happen over time is the night templars
will welcome back Jews and Muslims into
Jerusalem. And over time what will
happen is not only will these templates
become much more tolerant but they will
start to learn from the Muslims and the
Jews and they will pick up better
practices from these other religions.
Also at this at this uh in Jerusalem are
Christians who are considered heretics
by the Catholic Church. These are
Christians who disagree with the holy
trinity um and with other uh concepts
and that's why they went over to the
Muslim world. Okay. So what the
templates are doing is they're absorbing
all this diverse religious belief and as
such they become essentially
freethinkers. Okay. they become um a lot
of the religion now is based on reason
and logic because that's really the only
way that you can you can manage this
religious diversity. Okay, does that
make sense? All right, so the night
templars really become uh one of the
basis for modern Europe. But as you can
imagine this changes these changes will
come into conflict with the Catholic
church and as a result in the year 1307
the Catholic church begins to persecute
the night templars. They burn the leader
uh Jack de mole at the stake. Okay they
disband the organization but by
disbanding the organization you drive
the organization organization
underground. Okay. and a lot of their
beliefs will start to spread throughout
Europe and it will incubate the
Protestant Reformation and they will
actually in even influence the American
Revolution. Okay, we'll discuss this
later when we get to the American
Revolution. Um
um the reason for Jack Dumle being
burned is the Catholic Church accuses
them of being Satan worshippers. All
right, there's no evidence that they
were Satan worshippers, but they were
definitely freethinkers. they were
definitely religiously tolerant and that
went against the orthodoxy of the
Catholic Church. Okay, does that make
sense guys? Okay, so n templars I want
you guys to remember we'll be discussing
them later on in the semester. This is
just a quick introduction right let's
continue. All right now
um there are three different directions
of the crusades going on at the same
time. The first direction is to
recapture Jerusalem. The second is to
reclaim Spain from the Muslims. Okay, at
this point in history, Spain is called
Alandelas. And you guys can still go to
Spain and see a lot of this
architecture. Okay, it's beautiful. It
is extremely uh creative. It and it's
very powerful. Okay, so this is an Aldis
the architecture. Um this is some of
some of their buildings. Uh Spain is is
one of the most beautiful countries in
the world. definitely visit if you have
a chance. Okay. Okay. This is a mosque.
So, Spain um again was for the longest
time the most wealthy cosmopolitan
innovative place in Europe because it
was open and inclusive. There were a lot
of Jews. There were a lot of uh
Christians and Muslims all working
together uh in other lands. Okay. This
is a process that will take about 200
years where um the where Europe will
come and slowly conquer all of Spain.
Okay, but that this is also part of the
crusade. I won't go into history, but as
you can see it it takes some
time. All right. Um the last thing about
the crusades is they were also focused
in internally against denters and there
were quite a few denters throughout this
history. Okay. So so let's go over some
of the major groups. There are guys
there are hundreds hundreds of different
groups. I I'm only go going to go
through some of them. Okay. The first
group I want to talk about are the big
wins and the back guards. Okay. The big
wins refers to women. The baguards refer
refers to men.
um how they come in contact with the
church is they want to restore early
Christianity. They want to restore the
heart and soul of Christianity as a
religion of humility and poverty. So
they live lives of extreme poverty and
charity. They themselves live very
simple lives and they give as much they
give everything that they have to uh
other people. Okay. So think of the
story of the young man who approaches
Jesus and Jesus tells him to give give
up everything. Well, that's what they
do. A lot of them are pretty wealthy
people and they give up everything in
order to celebrate
Christianity. Their problem is first of
all they defy the authority of the of
the church. Okay? So they form their own
communities. The second problem is if
these guys are living simple lives, this
contrast with the clerics, right, who
are often fat, wealthy, and corrupt. So
it's kind of embarrassing. So they were
persecuted, right? Then you have a
people called the Walt Disneys who also
preached a life of poverty. uh their
founder um uh Peter Waldo was actually
son of a very wealthy merchant who gave
everything up in order to live in
poverty and practice the Christian
faith. Their problem though is they
believe that the pope
is the devil. Okay, the Catholic Church
it is evil because it's corrupting true
Christianity and as a result a lot of
them get burned at the stake. Okay,
there is a crusade against them and they
get uh decimated and destroyed but
they're still around even today. Okay, a
lot of their beliefs have are still
around today. The main focus of the
eternal crusade is something called the
albinesian crusade which lasts about 20
years. Okay, so this is complicated but
in southern France in a place called
albi uh this community practices
something called catherism. Okay,
Cathism is actually a pretty uh diverse
belief. Okay, but its main idea is this.
They believe in dualism. They believe
that this world that we live in, it was
created by the
devil. And why? Because this world is
one of pain, one of torment, one of
suffering. And there's no way that the
true God would create a world like this.
But the devil creates this world and
what he did was he
stole souls from heaven and souls are
pure right and he puts these souls into
our bodies and that's what gives rise to
humans. So we are these pure
um divine souls in these corrupt ugly uh
painful bodies. Okay. So the goal of
life is to discover that we are in
prison and escape
um our bodies and return to heaven
through good works, through beliefs,
through um through knowledge. Okay,
noises. So So these people are also also
considered
gnostics. Okay. Um their problem is not
only are they heresy, but they have
their own church structure.
Okay, they're they have their own church
structure and this church structure is
extremely open, tolerant and inclusive.
There are women inside this the the
hierarchy but there are also Jews inside
the hierarchy. And uh what's important
for us to remember is this is a belief
system in which there aren't that many
people but they're deeply admired by the
community because they call themselves
good Christians. They practice a life of
simplicity of poverty and they are kind
and charitable to everyone. So the
entire community sees them as good
neighbors. Okay. So when the pope
declares a crusade against these
Cathars, what happens is the entire
community rallies around them and tries
to protect them. Okay. Obviously, this
is a community uh that is being um
besieged by European knights and they
will get killed. What's amazing
is while the community is protecting
them, okay? And they know that the
crusades are only wants to kill the
Cathars, not the Catholics. Okay?
They're Catholics. The the crusade
doesn't want to kill them, but they're
willing to sacrifice their lives to
protect the Cathars. But also a lot of
them will convert to
Catharism knowing that they will die
because they are so disgusted by the
crusades, so disgusted by the Catholic
Church and they feel such a strong
emotional bond with the Cathars. Okay,
so this is a very violent process but it
does not destroy Catherism. Why? Because
these Cathars don't care if they die.
Remember we are inside uh um corrupt
bodies. So when we are martyed we will
go straight to heaven. So when they're
burnt at the stake okay they go
willingly they go happily and this um
stuns their neighbors the community but
it also frightens the Catholic church.
Okay. Because like they know you can't
beat people like this and if you keep on
persecuting them their religion will
spread. So the Catholic Church adopts
two new strategies to deal with them.
Okay. The first is they initiate
something called the Franciscan order.
Uh the the the friars um founded by the
Francis of Aisi. And this is a
brotherhood focused on a life of
humility and poverty doing good works,
right? Just just as Jesus said. The
thing though is they're within the
church hierarchy. They obey the pope and
the Cathars didn't obey the pope. The
Walt Disneyians thought the pope was the
devil. Okay. The main um invention, the
main response is something called the
Dominican order. Okay. So, you might
have heard the of the Jesuits, right?
The Jesuits were created in order to
persecute people during the Protestant
Reformation. Well, the Dominican order
was created just like the as the Jesuits
in order to deal with the Cathar heresy.
These are extremely well educated people
who will now use the power of the pen
rather than the power of the sword to
try to crush the heresy. Okay. What's
important for us to to remember is these
people who join the the Inquisition, the
crusade, they do so out of the puress,
the goodness of their own heart. The
Cathars have been laid led astray. It is
their responsibility to educate them and
to save their souls before they burn in
hell for all of eternity. Okay? They do
so with compassion, with generosity,
with mercy. And so they're
fanatical about it. They are absolutely
convinced the Cathars have been misled
by the devil. So what they will do is
they will go and interview Cathars and
the entire community. Okay?
Now before the community wanted to
protect the carthar so they will lie on
behalf of the carthars. Okay but with
the power of the pen you're able to
write everything down if you're able to
take testimony. Okay think of a police
interrogation you know exactly who's
lying and who's telling the truth. So
they were really quickly able to
identify who was a cathar and to isolate
that person. Okay. and the power of the
pen, this interrogation method was far
more effective than uh the crusades.
Right? So this is this is part of
something called the medieval
inquisition and this and this is um
something that will repeat itself during
the Spanish Inquisition in the um uh the
Inquisition against the Protestants.
Okay, does that make sense? So again
there's this um stereotype or this
misconception that the Inquisition was a
violent um act but there was very little
violence and the reason why is the
Catholic Church the doctrine forbids
them from spilling blood. Okay. So um
but but this was a very thorough very
effective way to deal with heretics.
Okay. All right.
So what brings the crusades to an end?
Why did the Catholic Church start to
lose power? Okay, so a lot of their
power derives from the belief that they
represent God, the legitimacy, right?
Well, starting in the 14th century,
there are a series of crisis. Remember
that for 300 years, Europe was in the
medieval warm period. The weather was
good, but guess what? Weather will
change over time. So starting in year
130 or three, the little ice age begins.
Basically, it rains every day and it's
very cold. So if you are a good
Christian, what do you think? Well, you
read the Bible, you know the Bible, and
you know this is the flood, Noah's
flood. God is angry at you guys. You
guys committed sin. Who do you sin
against? Probably the Cathars, probably
the Waldians, probably those who led
good lives. And you know they like good
lives, but you kill them anyway. Okay.
Um this leads to something called the
great famine of 1315 or
1317. All right. And then this will lead
to something called the 100 years war
between France and uh England. Okay. So
all Europe right now is they're either
starving or they're at war. All right.
And then uh this will create banner. So
you have these you know mercenary groups
basically these packs of young men who
go around killing people. All right. And
what does it the the final thing uh is
something called the black death which
lasts from 1346 to 1353. This will kill
at least half of the European
population. Okay. At least half of the
European population. All right. So let's
look at the black death. All right. Um
it starts in a place called Kyakhstan
today in central Asia and because of
something called the Pax Mangalaka.
Remember we last class we talked about
the Pax Mangalaka, right? Um this
disease was able to tre to spread very
quickly throughout the world. Um and
because Europe at this time it's poor,
people are at war, people are starving,
the plague decimates the population
because people's immune systems are very
weak, right? At least half of the people
die, right? And at this point, people
have lost faith in the Catholic Church.
And so now you have rebellions going on.
Okay. Um also and this is really
important the Catholic Church in 1378 it
splits
apart. It's and remember in 1045 the
Catholic Church split split away from
the Orthodox church. But in 1378 the
Catholic Church itself divides into two.
There are now two popes. The first pope
is in Rome and he's supported by the
countries in blue which is uh Sweden,
Denmark, England, Poland, Hungary and
Italy itself but you also have a pope in
Evan who was supported by France which
is a rising power in Europe at this
time. Okay. So this causes people to
lose even more faith in the Catholic
Church. So now you start to have these
rebellions um going on. Um so you have
something called the Dosinians and what
they argue for this is basically a
revolutionary party. They argue for the
fall of the church, the fall of
feudalism. Um and they want to create an
egalitarian society. All right? So in
other words, these are
protocommunists. Even at this stage in
human history, people are longing for
uh they're nostalgic for a time when
humans were free, open, and egalitarian.
They want to they want to destroy the
hierarchy. They want to destroy the
feudal order,
right? Uh this is John Whitecliffe. He
is an Englishman. He is a theo
theologian widely respected but he was
critical of the church and he wrote a
lot of books um promoting reform in the
church. He believed that the priest had
too much power. He believed that God
should be returned to the people and so
he himself translated the Bible from
Latin into the vernacular into English
so that ordinary people can read it.
Okay.
Um the eventually the church
um deemed him a heretic. Okay, they
called him a heretic. But the problem is
at this point he's dead. So what they
did was this. They dug up his body and
then they burn him burn him at the
state. Okay, because that's what you do
to heretics. He was already dead, but
they burn him
anyway. Um John H is uh a check. He was
in a place called Bohe Bohemia and he
was preaching the same things and as a
result they decide to call him a heretic
and burn him at the stake. But this will
lead to something called the Husk wars
when the local Bohemians will challenge
the authority of the uh Catholic Church.
Eventually this rebellion this war will
be crushed by the Catholic Church but
this will give way to another reformer
by the name of Martin Luther. Okay.
Martin Luther will start something
called the Protestant Reformation and
this will end the authority of the
Catholic Church in Northern Europe and
begin um a new age for Europe. All
right. So we'll discuss Martin Luther
and the Pro Reformation next week.
Okay. So let us conclude by answering
the three questions. What are the
crusades? Why do they happen? Why do
they stop? The crusades in the western
imagination, it's no different from the
jihad in the Muslim imagination. It is a
religious war. Okay? It's channeling all
that religious energy against your
opponent, right? And the crusades, even
though technically they end in 1290,
they will manifest themselves in the age
of exploration
um and in the conquest of the new world,
which is something we'll discuss later
on. Right? Why did it happen? As I
discussed um it happened because the
Catholic Church had a legitimacy
problem. Um the church was divided
between east and west. There were the
Muslims in Spain who are more open, more
cosmopolitan. Jerusalem was controlled
by the Muslims. There was internal
disscent. So the church was trying to
unite Christianom in order to channel
the religious energy and fanaticism in
order to consolidate its power and
authority over Europe. Okay. And why do
they stop? Well, they stopped mainly
because Europe found itself in internal
turmoil in the 14th century. But you can
also argue, and I'll show you later on,
they never really stopped. Okay, there
it's still going on today. uh the wars
in the Middle East that you're seeing on
the news, it's really still part of the
crusading
mentality, right?
Okay. Okay. So, I know this is a lot,
but any
questions? Let's let's try to clarify
some things that you didn't really
understand. Yep.
Okay. Sure.
All right, let's talk about let's talk
about inquisition.
Okay,
sorry. Okay. All right. The acquisition.
Sorry. Let me uh why can't I open this?
Oh, okay. All right. Good. Okay. So, all
right. So, let me go over the equation
because it's very technical. Okay. So,
in Europe at this time, there are two
types of authority. There's something
called
clerical authority and something called
secular authority. Um clerical just
means the church. Secular just means the
nobility, the prince who who is in
charge of that area. So um the clerical
authority passes judgment on you. Okay?
It it's only responsible for your
spiritual life, not your physical life.
The secular authority only cares about
your physical life, not your spiritual
life. Okay? That's where the division
is. So the secular authorities are those
who have the power to kill you. Okay?
The secular authority are those who have
the right who have who have the power to
declare you a heretic or
unorthodox. All right. So
um what's happening during in
inquisition? Okay. So the
inquisition is trying to figure out the
truth okay or the soul right because it
is possible that your religion for
example if you're Cathar that you can
lie. Why? Why? Because this world is
fake. Who cares, right? I'm fake, you're
fake. As long as your soul is pure,
that's what matters. So,
um you you try to look for these
cathars, but they wouldn't tell you the
truth. But not only that, but the
community was also protecting them. So,
what would happen is they they knew you
you were going to come in and ask
questions. You were basically like the
police. You want to interrogate them,
right? Well, before then they the
community would get together and make up
a lot of lies, okay? To protect the
minority of Cathars within that
community, right? These these are
neighbors trying to protect each other.
Okay? So, what they would do is they
would have these
informants who tell them maybe one and
three, okay, person one and three in
this community of 10, they are
cathars. So now the problem is how do
you find them out? Well, what you do is
like the police, you would interrogate
them
individually. And because the Dominicans
were well educated, they could write
everything down. Okay? They could write
everything down.
And they were tenious. They were
persistent because again, they are they
think they're doing God's work. This is
a crusade. They're trying to save
people, right? So, it's possible they
stay in the community for like a year
and they might interview you once a
week, right? If you if you're lying to
them, eventually your story will fall
apart. Okay? Does that make sense?
And the trick is to make sure that you
separate one and three from two, four,
five, six. Okay? Do you understand?
Because during the crusades, you didn't
separate them. You killed everyone.
Okay? which is problematic because a lot
of crusaders didn't want to kill
Catholics. They only want to kill
Cathars and then and then the pope said
God will know his own, right? I mean
like let God decide who's a real Cathar,
who's a real Catholic. All right? But
but you know that that but that was that
felt unjust and unnecessary, right? So
this was a much more precise methodical
way to figure out one and three and then
you burn them for stake, okay? to send a
message to the community, right? Because
what you're really trying to do is
threaten everyone else to
cooperate. Okay? And then eventually
over time people recognize that
resistance is futile. These people are
so persistent they will figure out the
truth and then they'll punish the
Cathars. So there's really no
uh point in resisting. Okay? And again
remember this is really important. The
Cathars own only a small minority of
people in southern France in France.
Okay? Before they were killing everyone
in southern France and this was uniting
all southern France against the Catholic
Church. Now because of the Inquisition
they're able to be much more precise.
Does that make sense, Eva? Okay, great.
Yep. Any more questions? Great
question. Any more questions? Can you
explain more about
Okay. Yeah. Okay.
Skateboarding. All
right. So, so in the Jewish religion, in
Judaism,
um there's a ritual
where the sins of the community will be
um put on a goat. Okay? So basically all
all the sins of the community um of that
year it will all be placed in a goat and
then they will let the goat run away or
they might sacrifice the goat in order
in order to cleanse the community of the
sins. Okay. So the idea of scapegoating
is to blame someone else for your
troubles. Okay. Or to divert people
attention to something else that
distracts them. Right. So for so
remember in the idea of
feudalism the conflict is between a
small nobility right and a large
peasantry. The peasants often um were
enslaved by the nobility. They were
basically called surfs. And as you can
imagine people would get angry. Okay,
they would get frustrated
and if they rebelled the nobility would
have a problem. Okay, first of all, uh
there were a lot of peasants so the
nobility might get killed. Another
problem is this is your economy, right?
This is your property. You you don't
want to burn on your own property. All
right, so the idea of scapegoing is
this. You have Jews who work as
middlemen. They're the tax collectors.
They're the um uh people who manage the
land. They're the merchants. They So,
what you would do is this. You would now
and then let the peasants kill the Jews.
And you think of this as a ritual
sacrifice. Just as in Judaism, they
would ritually sacrifice a scapegoat in
order to cleanse the community of its
sins, right? Well, you would allow a
ritual sacrifice of certain Jews in
order to cleanse the peasants of their
anger. Does that make sense? Like, like
I know this
is hard and I and I I know this is
disgusting and wrong, but it is a very
powerful political tool. And so, you
will see the idea of scapegoating
throughout human history. Right? So, now
that once the peasants have satis
satisfied their anger on the Jews, they
go back to work.
Does that make sense, guys? All right.
So, echo, is that clear? Okay, great.
Great question. Okay, any more
questions?
Okay. No. Um, so In this
religion, this world doesn't matter.
What matters is once you die. Okay? So,
everyone while alive is thinking like
how do I
ensure a peaceful, happy
afterlife. Okay? And the Catholic Church
is what uh allows you to have a hap ho
to have a happy
afterlife. Okay? Okay. But if you piss
off the Catholic Church, the Catholic
Church can tell you that nope, you're
going to burn in hell. Okay. So, the
priority then is to be on good terms
with the Catholic Church. That's how you
ensure uh eternal
salvation. Okay. So, they just simply
tell you
um yeah, it's a religion. It's a belief
system. It's a worldview. Okay. Remember
religion is the
culture which is the
worldview.
Right. Right. And this this is what
people believe. All right. Um so in
China, people believe that if I get good
grades in school, I'll go to good
university and then I'll have a really
good life. Right? That's that's a
religion. That's a belief system. It's
not necessarily true, but that's what
people believe and that's what drives
her actions. that that that's why your
parents make you study so hard. All
right, good. Is that clear? Okay, good.
Any more questions? Great questions,
guys. But any more
questions? Yeah. So, I I I need you guys
to really know this material because we
will have to use this material um in
future
classes. Okay. So,
um next week we start the Renaissance.
Okay. The Renaissance will take us to
the possible reformation,